all right boys here we
go we're
doing double liquid death crack open a
tall one crack open a second tall
one it is time for my favorite episode
of the Year Bar None do we have a famous
guest no is this IDE is this episode
full of insights questionable is this
the annual drunk ideas episode of the
Year yes it is Sam we're
[Music]
here why are you so amped what happened
this morning because it's my favorite
episode of the year and I'm drinking
double liquid D's is that uh is that
literally just water you've never had
one no is it just carbon it's carbonated
water that's all right this is like the
Austin national anthem is drinking this
it's it's like uh I still want to go to
the Hipster bar but I have to you know
cold plunge and um you know put sunlight
into my eyes in the morning so I I don't
actually drink that's a drunk idea this
is a drunk idea 100% so we had that guy
we had the founder of liquid death on
the Pod years ago like right when we
first started and and he was explaining
like his idea and we like uh yeah that's
really dumb now the company I think
they're getting ready to go public
aren't they yeah exactly it's the uccess
story it's it's like that you know that
one couple on The Bachelor that's still
together after 42 Seasons it's the it is
the one idea left standing of all the
drunk ideas so for those who don't know
drunk ideas was this um concept we had
in a stroke of Genius many years ago
which was there's a bunch of ideas we
wanted to bring up on the podcast as
like possible business ideas but they're
bad and we know they're bad and how we
had to bridge this Gap how do we still
get this half-baked idea off our chest
knowing that it's not really a great
idea using the cover of alcohol one of
the time tested uh methods of saying
dumb [__] is to say that you were drunk
and so even though neither Sam nor I
drink we call it drunk episodes and it's
basically where I show up buzzed slash
Tipsy high on my own Supply and I
pitched Sam usually it was me pitching
Sam really bad ideas and him reacting
but then I peer pressured Sam into
coming up with these it was hard for you
right well what I did I tell you I was
like I'm not exactly like a prepar to be
funny type of person I'm not exactly a
funny type of person in the first place
but like you love like preparing this
stuff and your best one ever was
actually called um the very longdistance
girlfriend yeah dude I'm about to bers I
was looking through the old list just
now and I saw the uh the secret camera
roll where you don't want to put some
pictures on your main camera roll in
case anybody clicks it so there's a
calculator app that if you push in the
the the right numbers in the calculator
it turns into your photo with your
secret camera roll back there how is
this not built yet what what are the
what are the computer science
departments that stand for waiting for
that this is not built yet I I don't
really understand the the holdup all
right everyone a quick break to tell you
about HubSpot and this one's easy
because I'm going to show you an example
of how I'm doing this at my company when
I say I I mean not my team I mean I'm
the one who actually made this so I've
got this company called Hampton you can
check it out join hampton.com it's a
community for Founders and one of the
ways that we've grown is we've created
these surveys but we'll ask our members
for certain questions that a lot of
people a lot of times people are afraid
to ask so things like what their net
worth is how their assets are allocated
all these like interesting questions and
then we'll put it in a survey and I went
and made a landing page so you can check
it out at join hampton.com wealth you
can actually see the landing page that I
made and the hard part with this is with
Hampton we are appealing to a sort of a
a higher-end customer sort of like like
a Louis Vuitton or Ferrari so I needed
the landing page to look a very
particular way HubSpot has templates
that's what we use we just change the
colors a little bit to match our brand
very easy they have this drag and drop
version of their Landing Page Builder
and it's super simple I'm not Technical
and I'm the one who actually made it and
once it's made I then shared it on
social media and we had thousands of
people see it and thousands of people
who gave us their information and I can
then see over the next handful of weeks
this is how much revenue came in from
this wealth survey that I did this is
where the revenue came from so it came
from Twitter it came from LinkedIn
whatever it came from I can actually go
and look at it and I can say oh well
that worked that didn't work do more of
that do less of that and if you're
interested in making landing pages like
this I highly suggest it look I'm
actually doing it but you could check it
out go to the link in the description of
YouTube and get started all right now
back to MFM all right so it's a it's a
new year and you know with the new year
everybody's trying to establish better
habits yeah so this idea is called habit
Island it's actually a remix of one of
your old real ideas called hostage
hostage SF hostage SF which was saying
Sam's uh weight loss guaranteed business
idea where he just comes and he grabs
you puts you in the back of a of a white
van and takes you away for 30 days it
deprives you of of food so you
guaranteed will lose weight well let me
just say when I say I like this idea
that's settling it short I love that
idea and to the point where I have now
taken your taken the Baton and ran with
it like I'm the anchor of this 4x100
relay what do they say in water boy he
goes uh not only can I do that but yeah
yes I can do
that not only do I love it but but yes I
love it this is the only podcast hosted
by millionaires that will quote water
booy and if you're into that combination
of of redneck and green wallet we got
you all right so habit Island what is
it I know so many people that want to
start putting these good habits together
they they listen to huberman they listen
to Peter AA they're they they subscribe
to Brian Johnson they're they're paying
attention to Brian Johnson's nighttime
erections they got like all kinds of
Health in their world they're trying to
improve their habits so habit Island
what is it it's a place that you go
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
buy an old school prison right a defunct
prison but we're going to Jazz it up a
little bit all right you're going to
check yourself in and not only you're
going to check yourself in you're going
to leave a hefty check at the door when
you check in because this is kind of
like prehab so it's you know when you
when you have a drug problem you go to
rehab they try to sort of help you
recover and fix your habits well this is
prehab this is before you have a drug
problem this is you were just a normal
person but you wanted to level up you
wanted to level up all of your healthy
habits proactively and so you check in
and guess what you want to establish a a
habit of sleeping on time sleeping early
lights out at 9:30 and no Wi-fi prison
wide so uh you know on habit Island we
just force you into all of the habits
that you need it's 42 days it's a 42-day
experience they say 21 days is enough to
establish a new habit double it double
that and we're going 42 and so we have
certain period we just force it so like
you know you want to wake up and you
want a cold plunge guess what showers
are only cold uh from certain hours of
the day or there's just a plunge and
you're just going to go single file line
hop in hop out get your plunge done it's
pure pressure everybody's doing it uh
you want to eat shitty or do you want to
fix your your habit about eating shitty
there's no shitty food we're only
serving super veggie here and uh we're
on the Brian Johnson diet by default
there is no other food in this island so
like host SF you really have no choice
we're taking Choice out of it and we're
just reprogramming you with badass
habits uh you know you want to have some
mindfulness again we're killing the
wi-fi at random intervals and there's
nothing else to do here so you're going
to have to get a little mindful with it
what do you think of this idea it's
great have you ever been have you ever
heard of like our friends Jack do does
them I've had a few other friends do
them they go to silent Retreats have you
ever heard of these so basically our
friend Jack goes to one he goes to one
in Bali but I've got other friends that
go to one outside of Austin and there
silent Retreats for five days not only
are you not supposed to talk they
actually only feed you light food so
bananas and like fruits and very light
food and you can't even make eye contact
with people and I've Got Friends that go
and do the and and and some of them
you're not even supposed to read so no
phones obviously but you don't they
don't want you reading and they come
back from these things and they they act
like they're transformed have you heard
of people going to these well yeah they
say they're transformed but they don't
ever say it for the better or not and I
I always question
that you changed yeah it's like that
phrase whatever doesn't kill you makes
you
weaker is that that
phrase well those are also upsells on
habit Island so if you want to go
sensory deprivation for five days just
for a small extra fee we have a room
where we'll just put you in and you can
come out in five days and see how it
goes uh I like the silent meditation
idea we'll just gag people so they can't
talk for for you know a couple hours we
are going to just all it's ocart menu
actually you could just sort of choose
how transformed you want to be and then
again it's baked in and you have
handlers that are handling everything I
say this in J but like every great drunk
idea there's a
sliver of a phenomenal idea in this idea
am I right or am I right yeah no I'm
into it it's I mean you're just you're
this isn't breathtaking you're just
talking about growing up fat camp and
I'm on board with that I would love that
stuff exactly see you have you have the
little gift to to sort of reframe that I
like that that was nice yeah all right
let me tell you about something really
quick have you paid attention to some of
these fake AI
influencers I have some of them are
really fascinating so there's this one
called the what's her name it's Karen
Karen majori I think we actually talked
about it a while ago and so basically it
was this is not particularly a totally
fake AI person it was a real person
she's a real person and she made sexy
like pictures whatever that was like her
old stick then she took 2,000 hours of
her video content and teamed up with
someone and they made a fake AI version
of her who you could talk to and she'll
send personal videos to you whatever
it's kind of killing it in week one I
believe she did $72,000 in Revenue in uh
I think she's using fan view which is
like a only fan style subscription
platform well anyway it's worked well
but
you know she appeals to men whatever uh
it's like that normal like hot girl you
pay to see her like do sexy stuff
whatever but you know who makes more
money doing the same stuff but just
doing a different way is the Andrew
Tates of the world and
so of course it's it's just some nerdy
guys coming up with this stuff teaming
up with like smart women doing these
things we need a fake tap and I've
noticed that like there's been these
guys on Twitter that are fake guys so
there's one named Derek guy have you
seen Derek guy his Twitter handle is uh
die workware and he gives fashion advice
oh he's not fake Guy's real right he's a
real guy but we don't know who he is
like you can't find a picture of him and
like you don't know too much about what
he's done uh you know that he's a real
guy and he gives great advice and then
there's uh Wall Street playboys and by
the way I subscribe I paid money for a
die workor wear like newsletter and then
there's Wall Street Playboys which I
also paid for it's Anonymous guys
talking about Wall Street which I'm not
even a part of but I find it so
fascinating because the anonymous angle
what I think we should do or not we a
person instead of these like attractive
women doing the fake AI things we need a
fake a fake tap fake okay okay because
what's the biggest downside of becoming
Andrew Tate or becoming Dam bazarian you
have to be them you actually have to be
them like I don't want to go to jail in
Romania I don't want to get canceled and
say all this C or I don't want have to
say this stupid hateful [__] in order to
like get famous I don't actually want to
do any of that but like like the idea of
having a really big audience I like the
idea of selling Hustlers University but
I don't want to live that life I don't
want to trap myself in that box so I've
been following this one that you have on
here Emily Pelini which sounds like a
bottle sparkling water but it is
actually as you wrote here a 23y old
funloving girly from La did you that's
amazing um and basically what this
person is doing so uh she's this fake
influencer she's she's AI she's a AI
generated girl but she looks real uh but
she's kind of like too good to be real
in fact they intentionally made her they
actually asked AI to generate like the
average man's dream girl and so you know
there's like guy hot and girl hot like
girls think a certain girl look as hot
and guys think a certain this is guy hot
it's like Kate Upton versus Kate Moss
yeah well said and so you go uh she's
got like 200,000 Instagram followers and
that's in like a year um and basically
what they do is there's a real person
behind it who films the video but then
they deep fake it to switch the body and
the face of this AI girl and there's
like they showed the Instagram DMS and
there's like celebrities politicians
athletes sliding into her DMs like and
they I don't know if they don't know if
she's not real or they just don't care
I'm not sure but when I saw this I was
like oh okay you know we thought AI was
going to take the job like jobs of like
you know bluecollar workers and stuff
like that because I saw all those Boston
Dynamics robots that like your robot
that can lift boxes and stuff actually
AI is coming for like the Instagram
thoughts and like that's who's going
first is is like only fans and Instagram
models um but I like your twist here
which is everybody's doing hot girls
nobody's doing Ultra masculine guys
right like yeah just Train Hey GPT GPT 5
I know you're in the middle of a
training run just pause you need to
watch these videos of
entertain Fight Club and that guy guy
who chops wood on Tik Tok and is hot and
like you need to like train the most
powerful a AI I need like 10,000 gpus
pointed at that and it's gonna come out
with just this absolute Savage gentleman
50 Shades of Gray [__] who is
gonna just take over social media um and
get tons of subscribers yeah we need a
fake Tate a fake Hermos whatever it is
someone who says what they have to say
but makes it so I don't actually have to
live that life so you know I could talk
to talk but I want to walk the walk and
when they get canceled cuz like what
they did was they were like oh this
Emily pigini she's brunette guess what
she's got a sister Fiona blonde if
you're into that right you just copy
paste you copy paste all the different
variants of what people's dream
personality and body and face are and
you create all the variants yourself and
you you own one of the guys who uh one
of the one of the people who is behind
uh one of these things they were an
agency and they had to hire influencers
and they were like this is a pain in the
ass These influencers suck and so they
just made their own and that's kind they
like pivoted their agency like start
making these and that's like the whole
thing this is the next Social Network
movie right like you know The Social
Network movie starts with like
Zuckerberg getting rejected from the
like uh the whatever the houses of the
frats at Harvard and he like you know as
his revenge is like I will create the
social network that everybody on Earth
will use instead and that's what's going
to happen here it's like I'm so sick of
these
influencers wouldn't it be a shame if I
replaced all of them and controlled all
of them right like would a shame if they
just did everything I ever wanted you
know at my whim and that's what's going
to happen here and the reason this is
interesting is like I because I know
based off my behavior I am buying advice
or buying content from these Anonymous
people I'm not buying porn from these
people yeah uh like like
gross like that's almost I mean maybe in
the future one day but these
Anonymous I never say never I'm not
dogmatic you know I'm
open-minded but like I just think that
these Anonymous Twitter handles are
actually really cool uh you know the car
dealership guy have you seen what he
does yes I've seen him I bought a car
from him yeah that's crazy you bought a
car from him he's got I'm never going to
pay $5 a month bought like $100,000 car
from this guy you literally bought a a
fancy SUV from him and you don't even
know who he is I don't I don't know if
you know who he is or not I don't know
who he is and I ask him for advice he's
got 600,000 followers now and he does
his car I know and I wish I didn't know
life was better when I didn't know
sometimes it's better not know all right
let me do the next one what do you got
I'm going to hit you with uh three names
of ideas that I want you to
pick frivolous lawsuit
company um user lose at gym or better
than
Google uh I want to hear uh the
frivolous lawsuit and then better than
Google all right frivolous lawsuit um so
I don't know if you know this but like
uh my e-commerce business got sued
recently and I didn't come to you D I
didn't cry on your shoulder but it
didn't it didn't feel good can you say
like a ballpark reason it's the same
reason every e-commerce business that
gets to any scale gets sued every single
one ADA compliance you know how outside
of buildings you have to have like the
ramp for like anybody in a wheelchair to
be able to get into your building but
how's that pertain to a website websites
have the same thing dog they have a
accessibility requirement by law which
means it needs to be like let's say so
let's say you can't see color it needs
to allow for like the gray gray scale
[__] or let's say you're blind it needs
to be able to be uh used by screen
readers so basically the text to speech
needs to be able to navigate like if you
move your mouse it'll say hovering over
menu click menu got it okay under the
menu you have this this this this and so
there's all these little rules around
this and it's like a total conversion
killer if you do it right because like
first you have to put this ugly badge on
your site that like takes the place of
where you would put your upsell or like
your popup that's like hey check out now
or give us your Emil address instead
it's like ADA Compliant and then you
have to do all this work that's like not
going our Drive sales um in order to
maintain compliance did you have to pay
a lot of money uh well we're still
negotiating but like on average these
will settle between 10 and 20 grand okay
got it there's just a law firm out there
that all they do is they file the suit
they use the same six plaintiff names
it's like uh I'll just make up a name
like you know Rebecca Jones it's like oh
wow Rebecca Jones has sued 3,000
companies year and uh why is that
because there's a law firm whose whole
business is and it's like a major Law
Firm but there's like a major law firm
in New York who whole business is they
just file these cases non-stop every
single day for every site that they
could find um that does is they've
automated the frivolous lawsuits in the
e-commerce space and you talk to any
e-commerce owner who's like you know
been around for a couple years or has
you know does over 10 million in revenue
and they'll all tell you the same thing
yep we got hit with it pain in the ass
can't fight it just settle 10 15,000
bucks and uh install this app this app
costs $1,000 a month that keeps you
compliant it's a whole bracket and um
you know it'd be one thing if this was
actually like you know a legitimate
complaint but these are not like from
people who actually have you know any
actual issue with the websites it's just
like lawsuit uh you know this frivolous
lawsuit thing all
right how do I make my pain into my
pleasure what if we did this to the AI
companies because there's an infinite
number of AI companies right now all
with a huge amount of funding and
there's a huge gray area around what's
legal and not legal when it comes to AI
so for example open AI by New York Times
for plagiarizing for plagiarism uh you
know if you go to uh open a if you go to
chat GPT and you say hey uh draw or like
make make me a picture of two brothers
who are plumbers um that like to eat
pizza guess what it's going to show you
Mario and Luigi it's going to generate
that art that's not their IP they can't
just create art of Mario and Luigi but
they do because that's what they were
trained on I am stunned that somebody's
not just suing every AI company and
being like cool I'll settle for 20K go
ahead or 50k settlement uh but otherwise
you're just going to be wrapped up in
this it's going to hurt your future
fundraising it's going to be an issue
for you it's more people are going to
come attack you if if I make this loud I
think there's a lot of money to be made
if you hate your life and are a complete
[__] and want to do that some people
are angry drunks that's like an angry
drunk it's like oh that friend he gets
drug that he does things that none of us
can defend and if you talk to any lawyer
who's like hey can you help me with this
they're like let me guess it's blah blah
blah and blah blah blah and you're like
yeah how'd you know they're like because
they're the only ones doing this because
they file 10 thou 10,000 of these a year
and they own another Law Firm that helps
defend uh Ecom companies what a let me
let you bake man what else you keep
going for the second one the better than
Google all right better than Google so
I'm talking to my wife and I don't know
do you know about this mug this Stanley
mug you know this dud it's in it's
insane I think they grew from 70 million
in sales to 700 million or around that
in 24 months that is correct in uh not
24 months in 2019 they were 70 million
and then 2023 2022 2023 they're at 750
so like three years that's that's insane
do you know the back story of this by
the way it's pretty fasting no I I know
that it's an old I mean like I'm from
Missouri and in Missouri it's like
carart and Stanley so it's like carart
is what construction workers would buy
and that's what I would I remember for
Christmas we'd go to the hardware store
and get a new coat from carart and then
in in the Stanley mugs used to be
thermoses that you'd put coffee or like
soup in for lunch or for construction
workers at lunch yeah nailed it exactly
it's it's like 100-year-old brand that
was like construction workers would use
it to keep their coffee hot all day
while they're on on site and then a
couple years ago this mommy blog out of
Utah was like we love love these mugs
and they were like we love this drink
and then they they gifted it to some
influencers they were like hey on behalf
of us like they're called The Bu guide
on beh on behalf of the bu guide they
gave it up and somebody at Stanley
noticed it and they reached out they're
like hey thanks for doing that hey you
know do you think your audience would
like this you guys seem to be big fans
of this jumbo water bottle and they were
like yeah we are they're like how about
we do this how about we give you guys
5,000 of these cups to try to sell
through your site they're like okay so
they scramble they get warehouse space
they post it and in like five minutes or
something like that it sells out and
then they do it again and it sells out
again and then Stanley was like whoa
there's just like cool mom Market that
we're not really touching and the moms
were like yeah this is great because
every mom wants to be hydrated we're all
like chronically dehydrated um this you
know this drink is cool it's whether I
have iced coffee or hot coffee it's like
this mug is great um but the color suck
and they're like what do you mean these
are Classics you know who doesn't want
like dark moss green and like you know
construction red and they were like no
no no you need pastel pink and so they
created some new colors and then it
[__] took off and it became the thing
and then all these crazy moments
happened I don't know if you saw that
one where it uh a car caught fire and
burned did you see this video what and
the Stanley mug survived there's a
Stanley mug in the cup holder and it's
untouched the whole car is like scorched
like the whole car is black and just
like destroyed and she's like she picks
up the Stanley mug the the straw is a
little mted but the cup is still good
and then she shakes it and the ice is
still inside it's like this kept my
drink cold even through a fire and then
the guy the sanley was like holy [__]
this is amazing and they were like get
this woman on a plane out here they
bought her a car and they gave her like
a bunch of Stanley and like it went
super super viral all these mugs have
this do you remember the nalene bottle
we're gonna go way back into the drink
drink wear history nalene bottle what
what was the whole thing with algae
bottle you could run over it with your
car and it wouldn't break you remember
that was like their I didn't even know
that no that's am enough which by the
way like we tested it it definitely
broke but that was like the thing like
these things are so strong they're
indestructible you could run over it
with car and it won't break right
because that's the problem I'm having
with my water bottle well yeah or being
in a fire your cars keep running over it
yeah yeah you notice Stanley was just
like they're like okay new marketing
plan arson um all right so back to my uh
better than Google idea all right so my
wife is in these groups these Facebook
groups that are always tipping her off
on these things and like what is this
group and she shows it to me and I go
why is this called better than Google
and she's like oh I don't know it's just
like I'm like what and she's like yeah
there's like this influencer she has
this group for her like kind of fans or
whatever but they call it better than
Google and I was like because she's like
because if you ask a question here
you're going to get a better answer than
Google like you're going to get 10,000
moms who have actually tried things care
are not sponsored and are going to like
answer your question and I was like that
is such a good name I sh I finger to the
lips my wife and I go this is a drunk
idea I need to go write this down
because better than Google what an what
an amazing premise and so true dude do
you remember back in the day this app
called jelly that came
out uh no what was so the creator of
Twitter was like my next ACT is this
company called jelly and he came out
with this app and this app was like kind
of like Kora but it was like you know
Kora is old it's like desktop based and
and Kora is um just full of Indian
people like just completely full of
Indians like I think half the daily
users are like in IND India or something
crazy so jelly came out was gonna be the
cool version of it it was you ask a
question on your phone and it'll ping
your friends like any of your contacts
as well as one degree removed so it's
only friends and friends of friends and
jelly for like seven days was the
greatest app of all time it was like
somebody would ask a question about like
you know what microphone is best for
podcast and you would get like Tim
Ferris to reply and then you know
because he's a friend of a friend of
somebody and the problem was it was just
a bunch of tech guys who don't actually
have that many uh you know sort of
day-to-day life questions like you know
in the same way that you know I call my
mom you know once a week to say hi and
you just chat be a good son whereas my
sister will call my mom 10 times a day
asking for her opinion about like which
you know which trinket she should get
from Ross like you know she just has to
like get an opinion on everything and so
I think women is the right market for a
product like this people who want an
opinion on everything and want to
discuss and want to get answers and want
High trust recommendations um so I think
this idea of a vertical Google where
it's moms asking questions to other
moms dare I say trillion doll idea I
don't know but that's that's what I'm
thinking what do you think better than
Google is some of the best bring
you you had that is the best thing I
have heard in so long there was another
uh phrase that we had said recently that
I was like that's a beautiful phrase
this is the top better than Google that
is such a funny that is like if Duck
Duck Go can get like a 100 million users
for guys who are like I don't want
Google to have my cookies like then
better than Google can work all right
any doubters out there to btg just go to
Duck Duck Go and tell me that this [__]
wouldn't work do your uh duck ducko user
voice
again privacy is
everything I don't know why they're like
a gargoyle El I don't want Google to
have my
cookies you're like Kevin from the
office I know my location it's like yeah
home [__] always I know your
location better than Google is brilliant
man this is awesome I love better than
Google this group only has uh 17,000
people I just requested to join am I
going to be the only guy in it yeah
we're early dude you got to do what our
friend did our friend just changed his
profile uh gender on Facebook to a
female by the way it had 2,300 posts
last month sorry go ahead crazy
engagement right yes yes I'm on to
something so um so my friend switches
our friend switched their gender to
female on Facebook cuz they were like
yeah you need to see the ads that are
being served to women like if you want
to be good at business like
is a non-starter you're trying to use
Facebook and Instagram as a dude like
you're not even it's like you're on the
outside of the club with your ear
against the wall trying to hear the
music it's like might as well just come
in you only get like flannel shirt ads
that's literally all I get it just ads
for flannel shirts on sale a FL shirt
and you scroll it's like you sure it's
FL we got another color if that's the
problem going it's one long conversation
from the flannel company to you yeah
it's like we have both colors red and
black oh cool we have
both
uh this this is awesome I love better
than Google you got any other ones so we
need to create Shan box or sbox or MFM
box manbox no not manbox it's got to be
named after someone so it's not a thing
anymore but my friend Neville did this
thing years ago and I bought one before
I was even friends with him where all he
records this video of him and like you
even see the recording where he's like
all right is the camera on the camera's
on all right good hey everyone and he
starts talking and he creates this
Mystery Box where it has three letters
written in there uh about like different
copyrighting techniques that you can use
as well as like a letter from him on
something he learned that month and he
goes I'm only going to sell I think a
thousand of these and I'm going to
charge $100 because I got to like
actually make all of these boxes and
it's a ton of work uh and he sold out
right away and he has all these photos
of people consuming the Box because it
felt awesome when he would get these
like he would just use USPS packaging so
it like felt like it literally came just
from him right and I've and I've heard
about Agora Agora is that big newsletter
subscription that we've talked about
that does like a billion dollars in
sales and we call them a newsletter
subscription but they actually make a
[__] ton of money from literally a
physical newsletter and newsletters are
all the rage right now I think should go
the opposite route and literally create
something on printed white paper a
physical newsletter I think you could
charge a100 to $200 a month for it where
you actually type something out and then
you could put like a book or something
or something interesting that you've
consumed that month and I think you
could charge a lot of money for this for
a sha box did that guy DM you about this
idea yesterday because some guy
literally yesterday was like you need a
Shan box I've done this for other people
here's what it could be and I was like
what I don't really understand they send
me an he goes I'll send you a Google doc
tomorrow uh so this is a coincidence as
they say I think this is a cool idea
your price sounded a little bit high but
maybe not right maybe if you put enough
value in the box right because like the
problem is you just kept saying you
literally type words on the paper and
I'm like okay yeah that's that's like
saying and then you stand on the stage
and the words come out of your mouth
it's like right so what's in the box so
what's in the box you got to say it like
that if you're GNA say that phrase
that's from the movie
um so what Neville would do is he had
three envelopes one had a swipe file
where he would print out the best ads or
sales pages that he saw that month and
he would explain why he liked him I
believe the second thing was like a
lesson that he learned and the third
thing he said he goes this is a mystery
I'm not actually going to tell you what
it is uh and so he wouldn't tell people
what the third thing was and I so I
don't I don't actually know what he
would nor normally send but he would do
these things and he would take pictures
of him like actually putting the labels
on the box and so he felt like it was
coming straight from him
and people love them it was so funny to
get these and he would like sometimes he
would handwrite stuff and just literally
like copy it like a fact machine or it
looked like it felt like a fax machine
copy it felt totally analog in old
school and the whole point of this is
instead of the inbox email inbox let's
just do the exact opposite and we and we
can take it one step further you can't
even buy it online you have to send a
check to Sean's
house you have to print off a coupon
you've got to
didn't that one no we're going to take
it we're going to take it a step further
dude ridiculous stuff gets noticed like
that last drink that you just didn't
need and now you tomorrow is is messed
up all right yeah he took it one drink
too far but that's a good drunk idea I
kind of like this idea a printed out
newsletter
box it comes to your mailbox instead of
your inbox I like the idea and this is
cool I didn't I didn't know about this I
remember back in the day there was a
service that did this and they partnered
with Tim Ferris they ended up dying
but it was a quarterly subscription I
think it was called they try to make it
yeah they try to make it too like uh
like here yeah and here's what I like I
remember when I started the hustle
that's what I wanted to do I was like we
got to seem big let's say we all the
time and I'm like no F that like now
that I know that like Mom and Pop is
better than big you know big corporate
company Vibe keep it keep it lame or not
lame keep it kind of like uh like uh
thrown together that's the way to do it
I want to see a USPS box I want to see
some of the tape all messed up when you
like tape everything in there that's the
way to do it so I got an idea for you
I'm drinking this liquid death and like
you said this is probably the
best best case scenario of a drunk idea
which is like it's just sparkling water
but it looks like a beer right that's
what this is It's sparkling water but in
a beer can and um so that if you're at
the bar and you just want to drink water
but you don't want to look like a wuss
you get liquid death right and it's like
I don't know man but it actually work
they uh Shane Shane Gillis on some
podcast he was like what's Liquid death
and someone explained to him he's like
where do they make it Flint Michigan
like what like is it it kills you he
like is that is that the water of
Flint that's good um so I in that same
vein let's remix right what is it great
ideas great artists steel ideas and copy
them or something like that that's the
that's the phrase we're going to do that
so not about you but ever since I gave
up drinking I really don't miss it don't
much about it did you did you actually
give up drinking or is it you're like oh
I haven't drink in four months let's
just keep going it's the ladder but that
a't as cool as like you know saying I
gave up drinking and someone asks why
and you're like H you don't want to know
I have a dark side so so the um the idea
here is the one thing I do miss the one
part that's really fun about drinking
that you can't really replicate not
drinking is taking shots or just having
that celebratory moment with a group of
people where everybody get let's do
shots we're doing shots no I don't want
to do the shot we're doing it we got to
do it give 10 shots let's do it
everybody get your shot boom you take it
you're like oh God that was rough give
me the lime right that whole thing I
missed that I like that when when when
have you done that my whole life when
I've done that I was always the the
let's do shots guy right like I was the
try hard guy at the bar I was always
trying to do shots yeah but when at what
era that was like probably 15 years ago
that you were doing that yeah but I miss
it I still miss it to this day that's
how good this idea is so shots are one
of the great bonding mechanisms that
humans have ever come up with up there
with you know fire and hugs and I feel
like we've us healthy sober guys with
two packs we're we're missing that part
of that ritual of bonding and so here's
what we're doing just like liquid death
put water in beer cans we're going to
make healthy shots that go in bars so
here's what it is it's a shot you take
that's just like [__] turmeric ginger
like all the [__] that gives you the
same like H face puckered up feeling of
like a vodka shot or like a tequila shot
but it's just going to be good for your
your gut it's it's actually just a gut
shot and U oh we're doing gut shots yeah
gut shots gut shots and people are just
going to go nuts for it that's the
that's the last part I didn't tell you
people are going to go crazy about it
have you ever had some so someone sent
me some non-alcoholic gin and it was I
drank I tried it and everything and it
was the worst it was horrible and then
our friend Justin May's amazing
entrepreneur he's got this new order or
this new non-alcoholic wine called
Shirley uh as in like Shirley this is a
dumb idea uh no I'm joking Justin it's
all right but like I've had some of
these like non-alcoholic beverag
I think it's so stupid other than
non-alcoholic beer have you have you
tasted nonalcoholic beer so you just
like this one gin exactly what you just
said because here's the difference is
beer I drink a lot of nine alcoh beer
because I find it like it tastes great
to me like I actually thoroughly enjoy
that taste and and it feels good and
there is like a placebo Buzz to be
honest that you let me ask you a
question when you were drinking were you
drinking a lot of gin regularly was that
your go-to drink did you enjoy
no it was light didn't like normal Jin
not going to like fake Jin were you
drinking a bunch of white wine back when
you were drinking heavily and had good
times no no exactly so the reason you
like the non-alcoholic beer is it
reminds you of the good times and these
other things actually drinks that [__]
though no does anyone actually like
whiskey like people say they do and I'm
like I don't believe you I think you're
lying that's what I'm saying they drink
whiskey because they have this sort of
like status thing plus they like get
getting
drunk shots you just like the bonding
moment of taking shots together and the
almost right of passage of taking a
nasty rough shot together this is a good
idea I'm telling you I know a good idea
when I see one this is a good
idea your idea is stupid this is not a
good idea you're just telling me to
bring like a juice bar into a normal
bar all right that sounds like a good
idea Point proven um do you have more or
do you want me to keep going you do you
do one more all right wait let me pick
uh just stand back and let let the man
cook I think it's really what what needs
to happen here I said I said I'm gonna
let you bake that's how that was my
attempt at trying to be cool it was
cook I'm so [__]
lame seing today on the P yeah let him
fry let him try do a divorce Island oh
divorce Island easy idea again question
not even maybe a drunk idea maybe just a
good good solid
idea a lot of people getting divorced we
all know that half marriage is ending a
divorce hard to get back on the horse if
you ever talk to a divorced person it's
hard to get yourself back out there get
in the dating scene you got baggage you
don't want to start back it's you know
you're going back to level one of
relationships after you've been in this
like you know deep deep relationship we
need divorce Island we need a place that
you go it's sandals it's a Sandals
Resort for people who just got divorced
it runs quarterly so every season
there's a spring divorce Island there's
a summer fall and winter class it's like
why combinator but just for people who
recently got divorced and you apply to
get in then you go and you're going to
be with a bunch of other people who also
recently got divorced even ratio guys to
girls actually maybe it's uh maybe it's
actually a little scoop maybe we go 6040
uh to make it a little bit better and um
it's just a place to just the slogan is
get back on the horse and we actually
offer horseback riding on to horse
Island also as one of our first date
options and it's just a place where you
know everybody here's in the same boat
this is a safe space everybody here has
the same intentions everybody here would
love to find love
again but everybody here is also and
there's no Stigma because hey we're all
on equal footing we're all recently
divorced so uh a few a few episodes ago
you were suggesting how you should buy a
school campus um and turn it into a
college or redo it then you said you
wanted to create habit Island and for
some reason you went with prison you
said you're going to buy a prison just
good
value that's straight up a value play
okay now you're talking about an island
I think you need to start acquiring land
my friend it sounds like uh you need you
need your own little Disneyland divorce
Farms doesn't have quite the
same but there's got to be just some
shitty Resort that's struggling and it's
like look you don't have the best
beaches H the weather can be a a little
temperamental here uh we really need to
refurbish this thing but we just don't
have the capital you know what you're
never going to win the the the the
luxury resort vacation game but you can
become number one in divorce getaways if
we just reposition the product and
that's what I think we should do here uh
cool uh can I give you um just a quick
one for the Run what do you got actually
I I got two for you I got two for the
rad double or nothing coffee it's a
coffee shop where you know instead of at
the end where it's like do you want to
tip 20% 30% whatever it just says double
or nothing and it's basically you flip a
coin and it's either going to be a free
coffee or you're gonna pay double for it
and the double goes to the Baristas why
is this a great idea have you ever heard
the phrase asymmetric upside because
that's what I'm offering you here a
coffee really only costs a a coffee shop
like 40 cents or something but they
let's say the price of the coffee was
four bucks if they can get eight bucks
out of every um you know every other
customer here on this coin flip that's a
lot of extra dollars coming through the
till and worst case scenaria you're just
giving up a free coffee it's only cost
you 40 cents in the downside and so I
think that there's it's a good bet I
think it's going to be like a slot
machine we're going to slightly skew it
so it's double or nothing but I didn't
say it's
50/50 it's actually going to be more
like a 7030 chance of you pank double
maybe maybe that's a little too
aggressive whatever the legal limits are
for slots we're going to go all the way
to that and it's a place for people who
like caffeine but also like to take
their chances dude the The Tipping thing
at those places is crazy the the place
that I go to the default that it starts
at the lowend is
30% uh if I owned one of these places
I'm just going to [__] with people and
make the default 3 100% And then the
second one is 400% and the third one is
500% I saw one the other day these SE
guys are getting out of hand I saw the
screen and it said do you want to P 15
20 25% and then it just had the amount
of student loans that that person at the
cashier owed no way and I was like is
that
true I think that's drunk ideas um
that's a wrap uh it's gonna be a little
while till we come up with some new ones
and we have another one of these but if
you like drunk ideas you got to go to
our YouTube you got to comment because
Sam never wants to do these and I'm
always the one being like people love it
in reality I have no idea if people love
it I love it and I assume that people
love it so I need you to either tweet at
us our our Twitter handles are in the
description or go to YouTube and just do
us a favor say more of this more drunk
ideas got to bring it back uh because
otherwise there's no way Sam's gonna let
me do this
again all right that's the
[Music]
pod
h